and welcome to hannity and tonight we're
broadcasting from the always beautiful
mar-a-lago in palm beach florida where
in just moments
the 45th president of the united states
donald j
trump he will join us for his first
sit-down television interview since
leaving the white house
no topic is off limits no question is
off the table
we'll cover joe biden the radical left
the future of the gop in 2022
and 2024 coven 19 the crisis on our
southern border the mob the media
and everything in between now without a
doubt president trump remains
the most dominant force in american
politics today
even now three months removed from the
washington swamp
when donald trump talks the world the
country listens
so tonight for the hour we welcome the
45th president of the united states
donald trump mr president good to see
you thanks for joining us well thank you
very much john all right so
i know a lot of people that are around
you every day this is what they're all
telling me
you're working as hard as you did when
you were in the white house
except you play a little golf more that
you you're keeping
an insane schedule seven days a week
you really don't stop well we're seeing
a lot of people we're seeing a lot of
good republicans and a lot of good
americans in some cases great americans
and we are working very hard and
a lot of things to do plus some getting
more involved for
a long time years i wasn't involved in
the business i'm
more involved in the business we'll see
what i do with respect to that but
the business is doing well and we're
doing well it's
been five and a half years of
investigations and hoaxes and
i see something came out just yesterday
about
the russia russia russia was a total
phony deal
and they hate to admit it but
intelligence they were putting a bounty
yeah the bounty the big bounty deal and
now they
say that it was a hoax just like
everything else so
it's a it's a sad thing you get
impeached for doing nothing wrong then
you get a second
impeachment for doing nothing wrong and
so it's been
pretty wild when you think about it but
and very unfair so we're working very
hard and i think we
you're going to see something that will
start to take place in 22 and
we'll culminate in 24 and you're going
to see a lot of big things and great
things for the republican party and for
the country when you look at the border
and
all of the things that are going wrong
right now what a shame at the border
let me let's start with joe biden
now i get criticized because the joe
biden i see now i can show you tapes of
him in 2016.
i could show you tapes of him in 2012.
and
to me he looks extraordinarily weak
frail i think it's very transparent he's
struggling cognitively
he usually averages less we follow his
schedule very closely
less than one event a day what do you
see
how do you grade him three months in so
he's going to be 79 years old
that is not old i know many people in
their late 80s that are
just as good as they were years ago i
spoke to one who's 92 years old he said
i feel better than i did
20 years ago 78 79 is not old
uh but he you know look i i don't think
it's even appropriate for me to comment
on that
it sort of speaks for itself maybe
people can make their own determination
i know that if it were me
uh they would be up and down going crazy
right but uh i had an instance where
on a slippery slippery ramp piece of
steel
very steep and very long no railings no
nothing and it was pouring at west point
and the last thing i want to do is go
down because when gerald ford went down
it was not good
now when biden went down the three the
press didn't cover it i mean if you look
at
well in fairness as aids said that the
wind it was very windy the wind might
have blown them over
did the wind ever blow you over when you
well air force one is a very big plane
and usually what they try and do is
shield the wind you know when they park
it you can turn it at angles and so you
don't ever have too much i've
never seen too much wind you can get a
little windy but not the kind of wind
that blows you over
but if you look at mainstream media or
as you say lame stream
media they didn't cover that if that
were a republican
in particular it was me that would be
the biggest story for the rest of
the year but let me let me ask the
question from this perspective
because there are hostile regimes and
many hostile actors on the world stage
you've got
a hostile regime in russia hostile act
of vladimir putin
hostile regime in china president xi you
dealt with him a lot i know
kim jong-un the mullahs in iran
looks like joe's already capitulated on
that now
you know them well enough i'm sure
they're studying joe biden
do you are knowing what you know things
that i wouldn't know
are you concerned about their perception
of an american president that
seems somewhat frail and weak well
something's going on because they never
did this with me that i can tell you
nobody was tougher on russia and frankly
getting along with
vladimir putin is a good thing and i got
along with them very well the
relationship was very good very strong
but they never encircled ukraine
and they never in taiwan china they
never
sent warships all over the place like
they're doing now it looks
very serious going on with taiwan and
that's a long way away that's 9 000
miles away they're right next to it
that's like
i mean it's like very close so
now there something's going on with
taiwan something maybe
is going on with ukraine this never was
a big subject
when i was president wasn't at all as
far as north korea is concerned i have a
great relationship with
a certain man that's got great power
over north korea
and you take a look at kim jong-un and
the relationship that i developed that's
a good thing not a bad thing
getting along with president putin is a
great thing you know we should be doing
business with russia we should be
getting along with russia
instead of forcing russia to go into the
hands of china
the worst thing you could do is put
china and russia
together and they're again together and
they get forced together the russian
hoax was very very bad
for the relationship that we would have
with russia but
i got along well with putin i got along
well with president xi until the covet
came in or the china virus or whatever
you want to call it
when that came in it was a hold but we
had it we made a great trade deal our
farmers are making more money than
they've ever made wheat prices are the
highest
they've ever been they're doing great
because china is buying so much this was
the trade deal that we made
but after covert trade just didn't seem
that important to me and
we did other things but it was too bad
let me go to your one of your signature
issues
from the first day the day you came down
the escalator that had to do with
immigration
you instituted policies stay in mexico
policy
it worked you built i think by the end
over 450 miles a new border wall
obviously walls work worked then of
course you ended the practice of catch
and release
now we see the exact opposite you've
seen these images on tv
i i i say they're biden's cages
i mean the media went nuts of donald
trump is putting children in cages
it turned out joe biden and barack obama
built those cages and the images were
from 2014 not 2018.
my question is this imagine well first
of all
your overall take on how dangerous this
is and number two
imagine if you're president and you have
these are trump's cages
overflowing with kids in the middle of a
pandemic
that with a high positivity of covid
what do you think the media because
there's been virtual silence on a lot of
the aspects i would
i would argue if it was a daycare center
you'd be shut down and
charged with child abuse they would not
stand for it
and they're playing it down as much as
they can play it down it's a horrible
situation could destroy our country
people are pouring in but you'll see
something as the months go by
like you've never seen before already
it's like you've never seen before
there's never been anything like what's
happened at our border
and people are coming in by the tens of
thousands they're walking in they
they we had all he had to do was leave
it alone if he left it alone
we were setting record positive numbers
and people would have to come in legally
and you know the other thing that people
don't talk about human trafficking
and drugs that's double tripled and
quadrupled coming in because that's
pouring in right now drugs are pouring
and we had it so tight
we were doing so well all he had to do
is leave it alone stay in mexico was a
big deal
you know that wasn't easy to get we went
through court systems we went through
everything
the wall getting the wall built and the
wall we were up to almost 500 miles
and completing it was very easy that was
going to be just routine it would have
been done routinely
the contracts were already there the
materials there was going to be done
very quickly
and we got delayed for two and a half
years because we were sued by nancy
pelosi in congress
not to build a wall i won the suits we
won all of the suits we won everything
and then they don't finish the wall the
wall is
imperative all of the things that go
with the wall the technology that goes
into the wall and with the wall is so
imperative
we had it down to a number that nobody
could believe and then
all of a sudden i hear this now here's
something else that i stopped money
going to three countries and then you
have mexico where have a great
relationship with the president he's
actually a great guy different
philosophy but a great guy
he put 28 000 free of charge 28 000
soldiers on our border to stop people
from coming in
and if you look at guatemala honduras el
salvador
we were giving them 500 million dollars
a year but they weren't letting us take
back these
incredible whether it's ms-13 but
horrible people
gangsters drug lords horrible they
wouldn't let them come back
so i stopped payment i said how much are
we paying them 500 million dollars very
early on
and as soon as i stopped payment they
called we would love to have
ms-13 back in our country they wouldn't
let us if a plane was flying over they'd
block the runways if buses came in they
wouldn't let you into the country
so we couldn't get anybody back now we
just bring them back
he ended that now what he's doing is
they want to give
billions not 500 million they want to
give billions and billions of dollars to
these countries i get along with all
three of them with the top people
all three of them but they're going to
be taking in billions and billions of
dollars
and what's going to happen is that money
is going to go to people that are going
to bring people into our country one
other thing
they're sending us not their best people
they're sending us people that in many
cases not in all cases
are murderers drug dealers human
traffickers
really been rapists really bad people
they're sending us people from their
prisons
those people are coming into our country
and of course that's just common sense
because all you have to do is
take a look at what happened in the case
of cuba take a look at what happened in
the case of
other countries but the three countries
you have
really some unbelievably dangerous
people coming into our country
they're not vetted you talk about covid
you talk about all
that's one thing but they're not vetted
from a criminal standpoint so we have
murderers and rapists coming into our
country
and they're just walking in and just to
finalize it we're people from yemen in
the middle east coming in
and they're coming in at numbers now
they can't come in through the airports
they can't get on a plane and we had the
policy the ban
we had a ban which was a great thing
from very dangerous countries
they're ending the ban they've already
ended it so the people can come in from
dangerous countries but
if you take a look at what's happening
with the middle east
many people from the middle east are
coming in through our southern border
alongside of mexico
what they're doing is insane they're
going to destroy our country
let me ask this he's